what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to kevin samuels
but before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel as you guys
know i'm trying to hit 20 000
subscribers
each and every one of you helps while
you're at it bring that notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos
like you guys do not want to miss one i
swear
okay wait oh my mic is lower here
see if that helps let me know if the mic
volume is okay because i've been getting
some complaints okay oh wait wait um
sonic crew shout out to the bonnet crew
hold on so i've been on here how old are
you
i'm i'll be 21 uh in seven days
okay and what do you have on the topic
so on the topic i agree with you
um i really think it's like a logic um
question you know doesn't really i just
agree i don't really have
you know nothing much to say that do it
okay
okay um but you came home for what
i wanted to have it's off of the topic
if that was okay
we could talk as long as it's about
something i talk about
okay well you talk a lot about
high-value
men high value woman my concerns
um i would like you know your opinion
your insights
i'm very young i still not very young
but i'm 21.
um i do live with my mother i'm
planning on you know like moving out um
i'm i want a high value man and that's
what i'm looking for
as a female i feel you know i'm building
myself
for that type of man but the type of men
that i meet
um why do you want to high value me
because who i feel um
i deserve that you don't deserve
anything
oh okay who are you
um simone chimon deserves nothing
nobody in this world is excuse me
what makes you so so special do you
deserve access to somebody else's stuff
um nothing really makes me special to
deserve access to anybody's thing but my
own
thank you so you don't deserve a high
value man you don't deserve it
nobody deserves anything you earn how
are you going to earn a high value man
by building myself to be a high value
woman
were you always with your mother and
father was i raised with my mother and
father
were they married no my dad was married
i had a stepmother and
my um mom i have a stepfather
but any siblings yes
they live with you guys on my mom's side
i was the only child up until
like 20 and then on my dad's side i had
six sisters
and but you're but you but you live as
an only child
i was back and forth i would go with my
dad's on the summers and i live with
like my mom and my grandmother but you
live but you live as an only child
but you live as an only child for the
most part
i want to say so because my grandmother
raised me and i lived with my aunt
so no i won it i i lived i was raised
with my aunt
i wasn't really raised well how old was
this here i have
how many children does your aunt she
has one and how does that child
um like three four so you were raised as
an
only child you lived as an only child
you're 21.
well how i think she said how old's the
aunt
man this is not a
okay complicated start this is starting
to go downhill okay
no don't let it go downhill no you're no
i'm just
no no no first off check that
i'm just asking you about your house
your structure you're your mother's only
child your mother had no more kids
and there were no other children living
in a home that's an only child
and there's something called only child
syndrome
only child syndrome is real it's real
i'm not saying there aren't only childs
that aren't cool as hell but every only
child that i've met
has some proponent of only child
syndrome there's something called only
child syndrome what
you might want to get that under control
because one more time and that's gone
what was that what is what
was there somebody screaming in the
background no
no because there's something beeping
going on all right i'll eat all syndrome
um but i do have a question for you
before i continue
yes you're 21
21 um why come on to the program with
the body though
well honestly i'm comfortable i could
take my bonnet off i know there's this
whole dilemma with the bonnets and
things
i don't even i don't know i'm
comfortable this is me okay
right but you want a high value man
my channel has almost a million
subscribers and almost
over 700 almost 800 000 on instagram and
it's seen by hundreds of thousands of
men
people 20 000 people in here right now
and you think this is the best look for
you for what you want as an outcome
i mean i've been sitting here watching
your life i could have sat here and
combed my hair down and prepared myself
but
this is yeah i think this is the best
okay and
okay and this is part of the reason why
high-value men
they care very much about how their
women think
because they're a representation of them
you come in talking about what you
deserve
and it really comes down to you you you
you
and as an only child there's something
called only child syndrome
only children tend to be very selfish
and that's what's kind of showing
through right here
it's not cute and i'm asking a nice way
and instead of saying you know what
you're right i probably should have
excused myself
right right that's what i was thinking i
presented myself in a
in a better light you could have just
said i didn't think about it
hundreds of thousands of people 20
thousand folks let's have a conversation
but i'm comfortable
it's all about me what value
is a selfish person in a relationship to
anybody
much less a high value
thank you that's a question
ask it again please
damn trick rocks
damn that's what baller
that's what you're raising entitled
spoiled
brats who think they're they deserve
something they deserve nothing
i got a question for you as a mother
okay
how confident are you that when your
boys are of age
to marry and have a family that they're
going to have
suitable women to pick from um
because i literally drill it in them and
then i
i tried my best now it's very hard
because i have four children
but i try my best to carry myself
um in the way that i would want them to
pick women okay but what i'm saying is
i'm not asking about your boys or what
you teach them
i'm asking about how confident are you
that they're going to have a
a decent crop of suitable women to
choose from
oh because um do you think they will or
do you think they will not
i think they should i think they will
should i think
so you think women so you think women
are training their daughters
to be on your son's level uh i hope so
no no no no that's the question i'm
asking
i'm asking do you think i think this
woman i don't answer aspirationally
okay because this ain't this is a real
question
you can train your boys up to be right
but are there women training their
daughters to be
on your boys level
so again i hope they are but i have
i have i am training my children my boys
to
know what to look out for i tell them
about the moms i tell them
look at the mom people
and okay you're training them right
you're still going to your boys
yeah i'm sticking on the girls and you
say you hope
i can't speak for them i hope okay what
do you see what do you
what do you see when you walk outside
with these young girls
um um
to be honest i and i love all black
girls
but to be honest the ones who you know
that i see are into riffraff and they
and they look crazy and stuff
so the answer is no
why can't y'all just say damn
see even what i'm showing this listen
even what i'm trying to show you guys is
even as a black mother
who has black sons you still have a
hard time holding women accountable
you can't even be i've asked the
question four yeah
no ma'am look in the comments section
stop stop man everybody in the comments
section everybody in the comment section
is
hearing the question women are sayings
just say no
every time i ask you how confident are
you
that you are you yeah um
i think that more of the issue is that
i feel like i'm gonna get some heat for
saying this but like with the
development of birth control women are
able to make decisions
later and due to being able to like get
married later and do all that stuff
women are given more opportunity to like
do things that they really weren't in
the past
um yeah that's confident that you're
seeing these women
and you say i hope so i hope hope
is not hope is not yes or no
hope is not confidence listen okay if
you wanna oh if you wanna
if you weren't on an airplane and i said
how confident are you that the plan
you're getting on
will not crash well i hope it won't
i'm not i'm not very confident about
that i never thank you
well thank you so so what does that mean
if you're raising your boys to have us
well because what else is she supposed
to say there's no good women left
like i don't know
you can look around and see that these
girls are riff raff or whatever
and you're not confident who are they
going to marry
so here's the thing to be honest i let
me be truthful for a second
and a lot of people don't agree with me
and it
i i don't think that a lot of women that
i know personally that have daughters
and people that i hear about that have
daughters are raising their daughters to
be
good good woman they say the most
stupidest things i've ever heard
like you you need to get what a man is
doing this and you need and you and he
bet
and i'm like well what is she bringing
to the table who what are you reading so
who are they going so then damn coach
your boys to marry if this is going to
be the women they have to pick from
i've co i have a saying when my sister
makes fun of me i told my son
i said when you see a girl when you
started in high school you see a girl
that you
did you like i said make sure make sure
if everybody has
they say free time make sure you talk to
the girl that's reading the book
did you hear the question i asked i did
that's a general statement about women
how are you going okay if you're not
confident
that women are raising their daughters
to be suitable matches see that's the
point
so here's what it is see listen listen
man go back and listen to this sector
because i think you're not really paying
attention
but people in the comment section are
listening and you're and you're
answering
because it just shows that the sister
code is so strong that y'all seem to
have a problem just being real
the answer is i'm raising my boys right
and i truly
in my heart of hearts hope that the
women are raising their their daughters
right
but what i see is riff raff and this and
that and i ask you
what about when your boys are of age
they're out of process and it's time
and they come around if they're seeing
adult women they're the same riff raff
what you're gonna tell them to do are
you gonna tell them to pick from that
real friend
no then what's the alternative
keep looking keep looking for who
keep looking for keep looking for the
woman that i did oh i got a question for
you would you be mad if they brought
home non-black women
no okay honestly i don't really advocate
for that
but because here's this here's the
problem
because she because i told my she gonna
come to my house and tell my son
um my son was like oh i wouldn't care if
i you know i wouldn't hear the mirror
she was like what your mother told you
that didn't she
well here's the problem here's the
problem
here's the problem that you as a mother
cannot talk to the mothers of the young
girls
and tell them anything about raising
their daughters right
that's the problem you can raise your
son up right but if the women
cannot start talking to women about how
they raise their daughters
your sons will have nothing to pick from
so if they have nothing to pick from
from the race
then what they're gonna have to do go
outside of the outside of the
african-american community
or marry somebody non-black this is why
this whole notion of mind your business
for us doesn't work because the boys
have to have somebody to pick from
damn oh my gosh
damn and i'm perfectly fine with it i'm
not racist i love all people
i would i would rather mothers like you
who are raising your sons start talking
to mothers or the daughters and say hey
my boy's gonna have to marry what you
doing with your daughter
now you know good and well that we can't
did you can't talk to um black women
about well that's you
well that that's that's the and that's
the problem
i don't give a [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ]
i don't give a [ __ ] i don't give i don't
give a [ __ ]
i don't give a i don't i don't i don't i
don't i don't
give a [ __ ] dog y'all you're going to
have to
nope nope if the engine is the answer is
not you guys got to check them
you can't it's nobody else's job other
than you as their sister
i just agree with him on some level
because
like how does that
you can't raise someone else's kids you
might be able to say something to them
but it doesn't mean they're gonna listen
yeah i don't care if they get upset i
don't care
oh i liked her i liked her i'm gonna do
my business in my
business funk that it is your
responsibility black women to check
other black women look at what she just
said
you can't say nothing to them so you're
afraid to talk to women who share your
reflection
well they they're not going to listen to
us and we're always told women
so listen to my critics and detractors
you should let the women talk to the
women and men got to talk to me and what
the [ __ ] happens every time
we ask a black woman to talk to and
check a black woman
and ain't my business it ain't my
business the women do not talk to the
black women
baby i don't know i'm white i would say
the same thing to talk to them they're
afraid to talk to him so if the women
are afraid the men got to step in
but the men can only do so much black
women it is your responsibility
to get your sisters in line to raise
better daughters for your sons
and if not do not get mad if you bring
home becky with the good hair
and i appreciate and i and i and
everything and i
feel for the for the young mother and
the woman there
because it was just like
it was just like the conversation i had
about all black women are women
and i was talking to the therapist and i
said do black women act like they belong
to us
and she just couldn't that answer and i
said well do white women act like they
belong to white men yes
hispanic women act like they belong
hispanic men yes the asian women act
like they belong to asian meat yes
the middle east women actually belong to
middle eastern yes do black women act
like they belong to black men
and she finally had she had no one she
had to say no
black women forget how you feel about
what i'm saying
so how is that at least
how many people have to say you're out
of order
to where your own sisters who are
raising boys
do not believe that the girls you're
raising are going to be
suitable for them and they fear
even being able to have a conversation
with you
on about it
how does that work if the mothers can't
have conversation with other mothers
i'm curious how you'd go about that
because
i don't know it just doesn't seem like
i'm just someone who doesn't like to get
involved in other people's stuff holy
[ __ ]
like if they don't if they ask me for my
opinion that's one thing but going out
of your way to give someone your opinion
that they didn't ask for
i don't know you let me know in the
comments if you think that's okay or not
okay
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel bring that notification bell
i'll talk to you guys next time